we've got a thing called a not inner
style so we're trying
i'll try and do the scene no i'll do the
scene and i'll
i'll do it uh religiously i'll get all
the lines out
well and then you'll like unpop the knot
in the style
and be like okay you can add this up to
like five now and there will be like
five
level five ad libs and then sometimes
you'll like amp up to ten
and it's like shootings on like level
ten femi when you're doing your
characters um do you find because
obviously
your show has got a lot of um like
african characters
and you know different voices that we
might have normally seen on a
um sketch show and do you ever worry
oh i i hope people aren't laughing at
this character i hope they're always i
mean i feel like
if they're so well written and such
funny characters you're totally laughing
with them but are you ever considering
like
you know we find that funny but are the
wrong people going to look at this in a
different way
or or whatever is it just something you
can be asked to worry about
no i think um i always just go my job
is to put the work out there and
and to be as honest and as integris with
the work that we're doing i can't really
be responsible for
how someone might misinterpret or
what i was trying to do or what we were
trying to do but i definitely think
um when the joke is with
the people whose story it is
there is more nuance and and less
occasion for it to be i mean i've
i've been an actor for a minute and i've
literally gone into jobs where they go
can you just do an african accent
because that will be fun
you know and i've had those words said
to me and it's like
why is that funny um so i think uh
when we're doing when we're playing
aunties and things we're not going yeah
yeah
it's accent because uh auntie's uh it's
funny we're doing this because these are
our aunties
this is what happens in in the party and
and and i'm i'm now considered an
auntie on the show and i literally after
that sketch
took all the jollof rice that wasn't
used home
um
[Laughter]
and i so i think you can't really go
wrong when there's that truth there
yeah and there's also universal
universality to it is that the word
like everybody's answer a bit
competitive doesn't matter where you're
from
you know and families are embarrassing
and there's always leftovers that need
to go home
that's for sure there's a whole lot of
like filipino people going no this is a
filipino thing
and then this is a this is an asian
thing and you know so it was
really really lovely to go okay we're
just sort of united by our crazy aunties
you know across culture
it's really nice yeah jamie um how much
of what you do
is based on people who you know and how
much is it
you just you know your own twisted
imagination um
well it's hard to say because everyone
in the show on the surface is very
stupid
um
uh no there's like i think that it's
trying to capture a general
kind of goodness and sweetness about a
lot of the
people that i grew up with and
uh went to school with people who sort
of
i don't know i think there's just sort
of it's more just like general
personality
types that you see over and over again
and you see like that they're generally
seen as flawed but
to kind of like tap into like a goodness
in them is is the sort of aim
like my character for example is
just like he just uh does everything
wrong
but assumes it's fine because he's him
it's like i wouldn't do something wrong
would i surely not even though that
thing's like
broken and got like got like black
liquid dripping out of it like
i swear that's like fine because it's me
what you know but deep down that comes
from self-confidence and maybe
he like was like bullied at school and
all these things and when you tap into
those things and
you know that like he loves his dad and
his sister i don't know i just kind of
wanted to
like as the series went on i realized it
took a while for me to work out what the
show was about
like series one just they're just
he's an artist is it after watching the
first series you realize what the show
was about
well i think i think in a lot of ways
yeah like i i like i
find the character reprehensible for the
first few episodes of series one
because i've been working on it for like
six years before we started shooting it
so i was just like oh everyone knows his
context because i knew it so well
i just sort of assumed that people would
just assume like oh yeah he got
because i've done so much work on it you
know i've got like white
photos of whiteboards being like these
are the instances where he was bullied
at school
sort of thing and it's like how the hell
is an audience supposed to know that
i remember a friend texting me like a
few episodes into series one being like
oh so he's actually like a nice guy deep
now and i was like yeah didn't you read
all my notes that i made over seven
years
you've just you you're obviously you're
nominated for your sec this is you're
nominated for the second series right of
sex education for this that's right
no first series no first series first
series okay sorry i just i literally
just watched second series
but when you when you were um when you
got the part
and you sort of sit down and read it how
much of it
are you like i can do what i want with
this like did you
did you i mean you know eric's a a
decade younger than you so were you like
i sort of have to work out what somebody
10 years younger than me
does with their face and their words and
their actions
or or did you just totally tap into the
character
and you kind of got him or did you sort
of have to build him how did that how
did that work
getting uh getting a script through does
that make sense
yeah yeah it makes sense it's a good
question i don't know how i'm going to
answer it
um yeah i think um like
like what a lot of the guys have said i
think i
i got i got the script i read it um
and i just there was a lot there was a
lot there and i was like there's a lot i
can play with and i was obviously aware
that he's
he's 10 years younger than me but much
like with the humor
i was like that's not something that i
can play directly i can't
try and like emulate youth because
i'm like i'm not 16 anymore so i can i
just have to play the truth of the scene
and it's so well written that it's quite
like hopefully it comes
hopefully it comes across hopefully the
youth comes across because it's coming
from the writing which is what i'm
saying so hopefully if i just play the
truth of the scene hopefully i
come across 10 years younger
but it was it was rich and full of a lot
of
a lot of stuff that i um
i i was really surprised that
a very middle-class
white australian woman had written this
gay black character so well
um and saw new ones and and aspects of
his culture and his his parents and
all of that was all in the script
already that wasn't something i had to
develop or build on um
and there was also quite an open
dialogue between myself and laurie
um and she wanted to make sure that she
was getting things right when it came to
things like the church and
other aspects of his cultural identity
and so
it was always a conversation on sex
education
it was always a conversation with laurie
and the cast as to where these
characters are growing
how they're growing and who they are as
people and so
yeah i guess in a way it was like a
constant building um
but i i didn't i tried not to go in with
an
idea of uh like
who he was in terms of his youth or
his humor or anything like that um i
just tried to let the writing come true
so do you do you kind of like tonally
or like energy wise do you match it to
what other people are doing in the scene
or do you go in and say well this is
kind of my scene so therefore everybody
matches it to what i'm doing does that
make sense like i'm
interested it's like who kind of who
kind of sets the scene in terms of
how big or small or how much energy
there is or whatever
um i think uh definitely our
our leader in chief ben taylor um
he he he sets the scene and i think his
energy
definitely sets the scene for the whole
set he's a very playful
guy and um and that kind of sets the
president to the atmosphere on set like
it's a very playful set
and obviously the subject matter like
we're all kids so well we're all playing
kids
so there's a lot to bounce off
everyone's coming with energy that
everyone's bouncing off and
when you're in a school building as well
you're always remembering the stories
like that you had when you were at
school and like oh i did this so i
drew a dick on this locker as well and
so there's a lot
of energy that's coming coming through
from everyone and um
and so you just bounce and play off that
uh
with in terms of my scenes and who's
who's who sets the vibe i don't i'd say
do you know with ben
we've got uh we've got a thing called
the nottingham style
so we're trying i'll try and do the
scene no i'll do the scene and i'll
i'll do it uh religiously i'll get all
the lines out
well and then he'll like unpop the knot
in a style
and be like okay you can add this up to
like five now and there will be like
five level five ad libs and then
sometimes you like amp up to ten
and it's like shoot he's on like level
10
the x-rated version
so that's how i see this tend to go it's
a very collaborative process
[Music]
you